NEIL: THE MARKETS FOLLOW THE
ISSUE, IS THERE GOING TO BE
STIMULUS AND THAT IS WHAT PEOPLE
ARE SEIZING ON, CHUCK SCHUMER
AND MITCH MCCONNELL DISCUSSED
THE POSSIBILITY OF GETTING
SOMETHING OUT EVEN ON A
LAME-DUCK SESSION, A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THIS UP
WITH THE DEMOCRATIC SENATOR FROM
MARYLAND.
THANKS FOR DOING THE TIME.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU AND HAPPY
THANKSGIVING TO YOU.
NEIL: I KNOW IT SEEMS A GREAT
LONG TEASE IN THE MARKET, HOPES
WERE RAISED A LITTLE BIT ON TALK
THAT THAT IS ALL IT WAS, TALK,
IT COULDN’T BE COUPLED TOGETHER
IN A LAME-DUCK SESSION.
HOW LIKELY WOULD THAT BE?
>> IT IS DESPERATE RIGHT NOW.
SMALL BUSINESSES WILL NOT
SURVIVE UNTIL NEXT YEAR UNLESS
WE GET ADDITIONAL HELP.
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS WILL END
AT THE END OF THIS YEAR, IT IS
DESPERATE WITH UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
STILL VERY HIGH.
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
LAYING OFF WORKERS, WE ARE IN
THE MIDST OF THIS PANDEMIC.
IT IS ESCALATING, HERE IS THE
GOOD NEWS.
THERE HAS BEEN LOTS OF
CONVERSATIONS AMONG DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS COMING TOGETHER,
A BIPARTISAN BILL, LET’S MAKE
SURE IT IS SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH TO
GET THROUGH SPRING OF NEXT YEAR.
I CAN TELL YOU WHAT IS THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY TO GET A
COVID-19 PACKAGE DONE DURING THE
LAME-DUCK SESSION.
NEIL: BERNIE SANDERS HAS ALL BUT
ADVERTISED THE JOB OF LABOR
SECRETARY.
NO INDICATION JOE BIDEN WOULD BE
INTERESTED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT IT?
>> WE HAVE A DEEP BENCH OF
PEOPLE QUALIFIED TO SERVE IN THE
BIDEN CABINET.
THERE IS CONFIDENCE BUT JOE
BIDEN’S CABINET WOULD REFLECT
THE PRIORITIES HE CAMPAIGNED ON
IN THE PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, I
WILL LET HIM MAKE HIS JUDGMENT
TO SEE IF WE HAVE A BALANCED
CABINET, BUT I’M CONFIDENT THAT
HE WILL CONSIDER THAT, THOSE
NOMINEES.
TODD: 1 VERY DIPLOMATIC ANSWER.
THE PROGRESSIVES IN YOUR PARTY,
THE ONES THEY ARGUED GOT JOE
BIDEN ELECTED, THAT HE OWES OF
THEM.
DO YOU THINK HE OWES THIS PART
OF YOUR PARTY SEATS IN A CABINET
AND EVEN MORE?
>> WHAT JOE BIDEN NEEDS IN HIS
CABINET IS TO CARRY OUT HIS
COMMITMENT TO REPRESENT
ALL-AMERICA, THAT HE WILL MAKE
SURE HIS SUPPORTERS AND THOSE
WHO DID NOT VOTE FOR HIM ARE
REPRESENTED BY POLICIES OF A
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
HE NEEDS TO GOVERN FOR THIS
NATION AND YET IN DOING THAT HE
WILL APPEAL TO THE BROAD
CATEGORIES OF SUPPORT HE GOT IN
GEORGIA’S CAMPAIGN, 80 MILLION
VOTES, A BROAD SECTOR OF
AMERICA, EXACTLY ONE PARTICULAR
GROUP, HE IS GOING TO REPRESENT
THIS COUNTRY.
NEIL: ONE OF THE IDEAS THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT IS BANDIED ABOUT
IS STUDENT LOAN DEBT
FORGIVENESS, HE PAID THE IT AT
AROUND 10,$000, SAYING IT IS
50,$000.
WHERE ARE YOU ON THIS?
HOW LIKELY IS IT AFTER IMMEDIATE
COURSE OF ACTION ON THE PART OF
THE PRESIDENT-ELECT?
>> BEFORE COVID-19 THIS WAS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
WE HAD A DEAL WITH THE SECOND
LARGEST AMOUNT OF DEBT THANKS TO
CREDIT CARDS, ENTIRELY TOO
EXPENSIVE TO ATTEND COLLEGE
TODAY, THEY HAVE LARGE AMOUNT OF
STUDENT DEBT, WE NEED TO PROVIDE
RELIEF BEFORE COVID-19.
NOW BECAUSE OF COVID-19, SO MANY
PEOPLE OUT THERE, WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO EASE THE
BURDEN ON AMERICANS, WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE REALITIES BUT ALSO
HAVE A PROGRAM MOVING FORWARD TO
MAKE COLLEGE EDUCATION MORE
AFFORDABLE.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEND YOUR
CHILD TO COLLEGE WITHOUT GOING
INTO DEBT AND WE NEED A PROGRAM
THAT ACCOMPLISHES THAT.
TO DEAL WITH THE OUTSTANDING
DEBT FOR THE COST OF COLLEGE
MOVING FORWARD.
IT IS AN URGENT ISSUE THAT WILL
LITERALLY PART OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.